did you guys catch wrestlemania at all
no but i heard about it my brother
texted me to tell me how good logan paul
was he's really good he is not even a
wrestling fan i was just watching i was
like yeah this kid's really [ __ ] good
i mean yeah these kids are just stars
yeah yeah pat mcafee i saw highlights of
mcafee that [ __ ] was incredible
dude yeah he got a stone cold stunner
and he was like drinking water and then
he got kicked out the stunner and then
instead of falling he stood up spit up
all the water and then like fainted like
he just got it he really sold it knew
exactly how everything we ought
if they asked you to do wrestlemania
would you do it though yeah sure
if you really yeah i was president
trump did it i would do it as president
for sure yeah get in front of all those
people i don't know you got to be like
vince mcmahon standing or something like
that like you can't wrestle yo
you know what you can do you could rock
bottom the rock how fire would that be
rock likes you yes commenting on your
instagram but to be a wrestler you have
to be a you know you have to be a good
actor so yeah to be a wrestler you have
to be a good actor to be a wrestler i'm
not going to act
i'm going to do it for real mark okay
yeah you're going to really write the
other thing i was going to say i feel
like you take it personally i am like
someone would try to do a move on you
and accidentally like hit your head a
little and you just like what the [ __ ]
you doing yeah i feel like you'd fight
them yeah i think it yeah that would be
fun wouldn't that be fun
just start a fight while we're wrestling
i think that'd be great and then they'd
fight you back and they're huge people
yeah but that'd be great for the news
this is how you shake it up yeah that'd
be great i just knocked somebody out
some huge guy you don't think that'd be
funny i mean i don't think you're gonna
knock them out but it will be funny if
someone's getting knocked out again you
know how big wrestlers are like
they don't actually how to they know how
to fight for real i don't think they
know how to fight for real yeah i'm not
a fake fight no some of them know how to
fight yeah yeah mcafee was [ __ ] it up
dog and he a little guy
john cena's 6-1 like 240. i think i
could beat john cena
in a fight
i do think i could what about the big
dude that was in uh ufc uh brock brock
lesnar yeah brock lesnar could beat me
up
he's an actual fighter i think he could
beat me up
he's massive that guy
done you just got to go
you know
give him a quick block when he goes to
taco you're good yeah that didn't work
before i know we're great when someone
was coming after me it worked it worked
really well he did bypass you because
you were so intimidating that's why you
got it you want nothing for me matter of
fact
he thought you were [ __ ]
the dude looked at me he's like i don't
want it and then he came right after you
the hazard yo that might be what it is
he did call me [ __ ] before he came
after no he did you're about to [ __ ]
yeah
yeah
yes dude i don't know if he could be
your secret service anymore dog say
again i don't know if he could be your
secret service anymore well i think he's
gotten better i'm straight also he
didn't have the tim's on bro like he
didn't have you your balance was all off
i was like i was trying to be a hero
with it like that yeah you were looking
crazy if you had the fitted hat i think
you could have you know there was you
know headbutted him or something like
that like it would have been good i was
wearing like three quarter pants like
you and [ __ ] like that i just wasn't i
wasn't flying enough [ __ ] you out
[ __ ] you also i don't know why my pants
ride up so high yeah
when i walk no so they actually reach
your ankle they do when i stand up
something happens you don't have long
legs every time you stand up you got to
readjust pull it down
because i'm fat now
okay that's because i've been eating a
lot duff fat gig
yeah all right
what about poutine at five in the
morning in montreal this is you no i it
was three o'clock
and i was gonna be hungover the next day
unless we ate are we still hungover
though yeah can we talk about how
overrated poutine is yeah well
montreal amazing city but poutine trash
is three great things which are fries
cheese gravy sometimes when you mix
things together it doesn't work out mark
bro he's right here
what's wrong with him
he's sitting right i'm sorry
i didn't mean it like that dude
we believe in your bisexuality
[Applause]